foreign
Britain is an Oklahoma City hi Britain
how are you
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up
so I've got a question
um my parents raised me in a Dave Ramsey
home where
um now I'm 27 years old and I don't have
any debt on my house my cars no student
debt anywhere man you got to go home and
kiss your parents on the list
27 years old with a paid for everything
way to go great moms and dads yeah but
this is this is my question I read it
somewhere Dave Ramsey's worth 600
million dollars
and I want to get into that kind of
wealth for my family and impacts that I
can make with that kind of that kind of
money
um
so I don't know how I get to the
hundreds of millions of dollars with the
kind of money that I'm making now I
think if I stay disciplined and
conservative I can definitely be
multi-millionaire but
um hundreds of millions of dollars
without taking on debt I don't see how
I'm going to get to that point I love
real estate my life my wife is a realtor
and that's what we were really looking
into a lot of projects in real estate
but what would you tell me I just don't
know time wise that's the biggest
constraint how do you get to that much
wealth
well I think you said intermediate goals
number one number one I'm gonna work a
traditional plan and go for the first
five to twenty million and the
traditional plan that we talk about here
all the time I'll put you in that
category but no you're not going to
become a billionaire with your 401k it's
mathematically impossible
so um and what you've got to do in that
case is study billionaires for instance
you could comb through and say okay uh
Forbes 400 are all billionaires now
you don't make the 400 anymore unless
you're a billionaire a billionaire is a
thousand million it's a completely
different Stratosphere okay and it's a
completely different discussion but you
asked so it's a fun discussion so what
we do is we study best practices was
study the Forbes 400. okay what do we
find there do we find a bunch of trust
fund babies nope
you don't find a bunch of inherited
wealth you find um
the true at Kathy family at Chick-fil-A
you find David Green at Hobby Lobby
you find
[Music]
um
Oprah
uh you find Bezos at the top you find
Buffett at the top uh you'll find uh
Michael Dell
okay you'll find uh all kinds of things
and so what do you find and all of those
are first generation Rich by the way
Walmart Sam Walton when he was alive now
that money is now dispersed to one the
next Generation down and I think each of
those members are still billionaires
pretty sure they are but that's that is
inherited wealth there because Sam the
old man started Walmart but it's Walmart
money so what you do find when you're
going through there and I've noticed
this is the vast majority of them are uh
it's like 69 percent of first generation
rich
okay so that means you get that it's
possible in other words uh then number
two how did they do it well it wasn't
funding their 401K that's not that
doesn't get you to a billion a thousand
million doesn't get you there okay uh
what they typically did was start an
Enterprise start a business
so I mean you've got Gates starting
Microsoft you got Dell starting Dell you
got Chick-fil-A you got Hobby Lobby
you've got Oprah is an Enterprise
Oprah's not a brand Oprah is an Empire
uh a huge brand but it's got I mean
hundreds and hundreds of employees and
so uh I mean I know she's a person but
she's also a massive Enterprise and so
uh that kind of so each of these people
uh the I
I think almost all of them started
businesses and the business made them
wealthy the heat the explosion of the
business
and or they took them public yeah and
the stock made them rich I mean
obviously
that's uh uh Buffett's situation
um Phil Knight yeah Phil Knight Nike
yeah that's another one so those are but
they almost all were business
enterprises and they grew large
businesses
um and in my case that's where my money
came from the vast majority of it's from
running from Ramsay I've got 1100 team
members we do 300 million a year in
gross gross revenues here at Ramsey and
so yeah I mean obviously that's where
our my personal net worth came from